The visitor pattern is quite powerful and popular however there are some
issues with it. First off the implementation of the operations are placed in
a different place from the Elements being operated on.
It means that the operations are kept together. The elements are kept together
but in a sense encapsulation is compromised because those two are separated.
Second consequence is that adding new operations is straightforward,
you just have new classes on the visitor side of things.
In a sense you are actually extending the operations on a class without changing
the class itself on the other hand adding new element types is hard.
This would break the data structure and cause a lot of reprogramming.
Final consequences, if you need to, visitors can accumulate state as I
indicated before an example would be collecting statistics.